sky cher c'est le petit nom du premier
service d'autopartage inter entreprises
du département
un projet à l'initiative de saint
quentin en yvelines et du club climat
énergie objectif réduire les émissions
de co2 des véhicules
c'est à une flotte qui sera donc en
partage pour les salariés les
collaborateurs des entreprises notamment
pour leurs déplacements domicile travail
et aussi pour leurs déplacements
professionnels et parfois privés lorsque
la flotte sera disponible
neuf véhicules électriques et hybrides
aujourd'hui et bientôt un dixième en
2021 mise en commun entre trois
entreprises est né dix banque populaire
val de france et léonie l'ademe estime
qu' on peut pour une voiture partagée
économiser 10 voitures qu'on aurait
acheté par ailleurs si on n'avait pas eu
ce type de solutions l'objectif c'est
qu'on puisse réduire assez vite nos
flottes d'entreprise pour dégager des
moyens supplémentaires pour développer
le service
on met à disposition cette flotte de
véhicules pour que nos collaborateurs
puissent se tester à l' usage des
véhicules hybrides qui sont pas
forcément accessibles pour tous nos
collaborateurs
c'est quand même peu rassurant pour
entreprises de mettre à disposition de
son de ses salariés un véhicule qui sont
dans les meilleurs contrats lité de
fonctionnement de sécurité et si en plus
il est électrique ou hybride
c'est un rat bénéfices supplémentaires
si ce service est le premier des
yvelines
le club qui m'a énergie et
l'agglomération aimerait développer plus
encore l'autopartage inter entreprises
voire même l'ouvrir aux particuliers un
dispositif similaire pourrait d'ailleurs
voir le jour prochainement à trappes